lego star wars the force
Wiggins is the galaxy's
overflowing with daring heroes dastardly
villains droids Lego bricks and heart
strapping for epic dogfights across the
galaxy yvaine TIE fighters through the
derelict ruins of jakku save your
friends on taco donna and battle massive
star destroyers empty hyper edit become
accustomed to such expects blaster
battles put you right in the thick of
the action dodge incoming enemy fire and
when the moment is right strike back
multi builds offer unique ways to solve
puzzles and engage enemies with you
build a subterranean spider droid
will you opt for a strategy of a
different flavor with multiple options
you'll find creative ways to get out of
trouble
brand new adventures expand the story of
the force awakens discover how han and
chewie captured the rat dogs live the
continuing Adventures of Poe Dameron you
get as far away from here as you can dig
deeper into the backstory of lor san
tekka and more without the Jedi that can
be no balance in the toy
nothing gets you closer to the galaxy's
greatest adventure in lego star wars the
force awakens
we ordered the deluxe edition to receive
early access to the Empire Strikes Back
character back